we got this article from SFGate more
U-Haul trucks left California than any
other state in 2022 and do you know why
because there is human excrement
littering the streets in all of their
major cities I don't care if you're
going to lasf Sacramento whatever it's
everywhere it's everywhere Fresno it's
Fresno oh it's bad have you heard about
the poop Department in San Francisco
yeah they have an app called Snap crap
take a picture on the side is that for
real that's a real thing snap crap so
this is the point
uh snap crap on that was to warn people
of where the poop is
the health department go and clean it up
it's real snap crap snap crap but it
doesn't even matter because it's just
Brown like the map there's so many poop
nodes placed it's just a brown splotch
over San Francisco
this is what happens with
too much government loss of family yeah
loss of family the issue isn't
necessarily government but I don't
completely disagree with you if you have
people who are family oriented family
first if they have some kind of belief
in something Beyond them be it God or
otherwise like a moral sense which I do
think comes from God in a lot in a lot
of ways but I think there can be people
who are moral without believing in God
if if you have that then you have people
in government with Scruples you have a
cop who's like I can't give someone a
fake ticket a bogus ticket I can't
wrongly arrest this person that'd be
wrong I'll be punished God will be mad
at me my family will be mad at me my
community will be met with me but now
because everyone is this I'm the only
one that matters you get bad cops you
get bad government you get poop all over
the streets you get people saying I
could solve the problem but I'd like to
campaign off of it to get reelected so I
won't I see some problems with like
honor thy mother and thy father which is
super important that's part of the tour
that's part of the Ten Commandments is
it not uh and then uh what happens is
people with bad parents or parents that
aren't there people that don't know
their dads like this is kind of an
endemic thing in our society how do you
honor someone that you hate that wronged
you that that set you in a path of
emptiness like how do you honor someone
like that that's why I always recommend
people listen to Jesse Lee Peterson
Jesse Lee Peterson says forgive your
mother because so many people had
mothers that uh didn't do right by them
I actually brought this book I didn't
even know how to talk about this
specifically but this is the Contin
minimum concept I brought this literally
just because it says that mothers that
don't constantly hold their babies it's
like the babies feel neglected and
people grow out without a sense of love
and that's people that have mothers that
are at least trying a little bit people
without parents at all or your mother
was abusive so that's going to screw you
up Jesse Lee Peterson says forgive your
mother it helps so many people like
forgive their mother return to their
father connect to God so I love Jesse
Lee Peterson for that and since I
brought him up uh he's uh in a
commercial I said I'm a right-wing
entrepreneur I'm putting out this stuff
Alpha jerky at bigclubusa.com and Jesse
Lee Peterson there's a hilarious
commercial that that we put out with uh
Jesse Lee it's on uh Patriot Jay's uh
Twitter right now banned from Twitter by
the way patriotic Elon Musk restore
Patriot J restore Patriot Day today yo
that jerky's legit dude oh yeah it's the
only preservative and it is salt it's
salt no sugar and what water so this guy
Andrew is like I got I got something you
might want to check out I was like I
don't know man he's like it's jerky and
I might look at it no sugar no garbage
salt ground pepper and beef so this is
what happens with good family values you
get the seed oils and the garbage out of
your food you don't buy a U-Haul to flee
California you move to Florida or you
live in Florida already speaking of
where you at now where are you based out
of Arizona it's the greatest state but
if we don't have a miracle people please
pray for Kerry Lake's appeal I need that
state to stay red I don't want to live
in a state where some democrat Governors
decides oh guess what uh there's a new
uh chicken flu and everybody stay inside
your house or you get arrested those
U-Hauls leaving California are going to
Arizona
in Texas it's a great state but don't
the article actually mentions that a lot
of people are moving to Texas oh wow and
the fact is the fastest growing state in
the United States is Florida but the
number one state that people are leaving
according to the latest data is New
Jersey Illinois New York and Connecticut
New Jersey let me let me tell you about
something about New Jersey we were there
for a little while
and I was actually really excited by the
idea I was like we can we can fix this
place we can we can build a culture here
New Jersey has a brain drain among the
Young no young person wants to live in
New Jersey so they leave right away and
this makes the state stagnant and bad
and then you get bad government and
problems which perpetuate the cycle the
worse the government gets the more
nobody wants to be there so I'm like we
should set something up here and then
start pushing back it's not possible I
just I just feel like you can't be done
so we left it's the epitome of like a
state being run by its capital or it's a
swap State it's like New York has at
least Upstate New York but Jersey
doesn't the whole thing is just a swamp
yeah there's a reason we call it dirty
Jersey there's a reason the taxes are so
high there's a reason you can't defend
yourself it's it's an absolutely
horrible state that a lot of New Yorkers
who tapped out of New York City just
went to in order to get away from all
the yuppies and all the urban
professionals taking over uh what used
to be a great City New York City did you
go to Jersey much when you lived in New
York absolutely not are you kidding me
did you ever go to Manhattan or were you
just kind of a Borough guy sometimes it
depends I was mainly just in Brooklyn so
yeah a broken guy twice as both instead
of both it depends it was my accent was
worse before now it's I wish I could do
a video of like when it was yes my
earlier videos on my channel it's
horrible and I cringe watching it all
the time it's absolutely embarrassing
but uh yeah I got videos on my channel
from like 2008 to 2007 and it was Heavy
then yeah I feel like you'd be like hey
Luke did you want the vanilla ice cream
and the chocolate both I'd be like
b-o-a-f both but I've been working on my
language
enough to believe this I don't know if
Luke gets enough credit for being the
legend I don't journalist that he is
this guy was confronting Larry
Silverstein uh Jacob Rothschild I
believe Eric Schmidt this guy he got his
own channel demonetized by yelling at
the CEO of Google this guy is one of
them
independent journalist in this era and I
just don't know if he gets enough credit
for that we broke the spirit cooking
story Cassandra Fairbanks on we are
change 2016 we helped swing that
election yep it was Cassandra Fairbanks
and you working as the top editors we
had a staff of like 30 people we were
releasing articles we broke that Spirit
cooking story uh and we were kicking
butt we were doing a lot of incredible
work but uh I made I made the mistake of
having
um uh left-wing people and right-wing
people and I said look let the best
ideas win we're gonna debate them if a
right-wing person puts out an article
you disagree with right at counter
argument and let's actually have this
debate on the platform it worked for a
while and then everyone started fighting
each other and then there was a Civil
War and it got bad and I'm like I just I
just gave up so but it was it was it was
the good old heydays of actual
journalism of actual investigations of
actually talking about the stories that
mattered and we had a full frontal
attack by the establishment by the court
media that went after us hardcore and I
mean I'm still I'm still keeping at it
but um those are different days so let
me ask you about Texas then do you think
the people leaving California are good
people do you think the people leaving
California are like based and they're
like I don't want to be here anymore
let's go to Texas I think they have to
be right but is it is it possible
they're also just like default liberals
who are like things are really bad let's
go vote for the same thing in Texas
locusts they're like locusts I think a
lot of these people they didn't learn a
thing they're just like hey like Tim
just said it's really bad here let's go
somewhere else and they don't learn why
is it bad remember that guy who was like
I vote Democrat but this is really bad
so I'm going to Florida where I'll keep
voting Democrat and it's like no no no
no no don't you get it I don't think so
I think looking at the the election
numbers especially from Florida we saw
that this biggest transplant movement
especially from New York City with
predominantly right-wingers we saw that
a lot of people are even estimating that
Lee zeldin could have won New York as
Governor if those people didn't flee to
Florida Florida became from came from a
purple state to a solid red state that
happened because the same people who
think the same way are moving to places
that they think they're going to be
respected
um and I think that's the majority of
people leaving California now the only
thing I'll say to whether Lee zeldin
could have won is there was a
documentary called kill chain this is on
HBO and it has people like Kamala Harris
talking about hacking elections and
saying that elections can be easily
hacked so I don't know if any amount of
people not fleeing to Florida would have
fixed New York and I have I have a book
that I'm putting out soon you'll see
excerpts of it on my sub stack that I
just launched the
andrewmeyer.substack.com but the book is
called blatant fraud the stealing of
Arizona and I get in depth of what's
going on in the just like HBO did just
like uh 20 years ago they had a movie
blackboxvoting.org and they talked about
what was going on with the George Bush
elections you know as I said to John
Kerry the voting machines counting
backwards so this stuff is not new let
me ask you
in all your wisdom how do we stop the
problem of poop in the streets of
California but as a more serious take on
the question if people are fleeing it's
because of things like that and these
problems is there is there even a
solution to it because I got to be
honest what can the government do that
it can't that as it's already failed at
and then if you do nothing people will
just stay there and poop in the street
it's all about the individual every
single person you have to you have to do
your utmost you better be praying to God
you can fast you can I recommend this
this I'm going to give you this by the
way Tim this is the Zohar I have one
really yeah what is it this is literally
the Holy Grail I kid you not like you
can look in the Catholic encyclopedia
what is the Holy Grail do some research
eventually you'll find this book this is
the soul of the Torah the soul of the
Bible and just having this is so much
light if enough people in the world have
just have this the Zohar I used to give
these out up and down the coast of
Florida because there used to be so many
hurricanes they started this project
give out the Zohar along the coast
Florida there was no hurricanes for a
decade not one and you could say oh well
that's just a coincidence but I could
tell you story after story after Story
literal Miracles with this book you
already have one I don't I don't care
somebody somebody came on the show
before and and give this one as well
dude I'll take it amazing yeah let's I
won't absorb I'll put it under my
pillows thank you yeah okay is it bound
backwards that's the first thing well
because it's got It's got a Hebrew
letters it's got Aaron made oh it reads
right to left yeah but that house also
has English in it so you can learn and
study and and this is saying it uh
foundational work in the literature of
Jewish mystical thought known as
Kabbalah yep and so the Kabbalah is like
the mystical nature of Judaism there's
four levels of Torah study the deepest
level the so the secrets that's where
you're studying Kabbalah and the
righteous say ravaslog said in our
generation we have to study the secrets
first if we don't study this stuff it
makes the Torah dry and on our
generation this is the lowest generation
of all time I think it's pretty obvious
uh we need the highest light so that's
that's why this book which used to be
buried for thousands this was buried
kept secret used to be you had to be 40
years old in a Jew and chosen by a
teacher and a man uh before you'd be
allowed to study this that there's
people that still believe this
prohibition is exists today it was
overturned 500 years ago by
avrahamasalai but this stuff was Kept
Secret and now this light is available
for Our Generation because our
generation is so low uh is it like
sacred geometry and chakras unload like
fixing your body posture so you can get
in touch with God fasting and things
like that Gematria definitely like if
you read the Zohar you will find some
things that make your your head uh
explode I don't know you'll be very
excited if you like gamatra and you
start reading the Zohar you'll be very
excited well thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time